the jurgen experience i was talking to
you a little bit about the video game
stuff
right yeah yeah when i was in my mid-20s
people couldn't wait for warcraft 3 to
come out it was like the new [ __ ] coming
out
i remember right there like it's going
to come out and they delayed it
and it finally came out and i didn't i
didn't have any money then and i got
warcraft 2.
and warcraft 2 the interface for the
kids out there listening
um it's like god interface like you're
little peasants and paladins and you're
moving them around where warcraft 3 is
more 3d
what the [ __ ] i'm explaining video games
um and i got on there and because the
entire world was waiting for warcraft 3
no one was playing warcraft 2. so i was
the god of warcraft
2. you know when you go on online games
you get a game really quick
uh-huh this was back in the this is like
20 years ago so
wait i'm 24 yeah it's like 20 years ago
so i'd get on the game
and i'd be waiting i would start a map
and i'm like who wants to play and i'd
wait and have to wait
for people to join my career was just
getting started i was in a wonderful
relationship with this
woman and that i dated for seven years
my life was like
on the up and up and
this thing completely took over my life
have you ever seen this documentary
called web junkies
about um the internet problem in china
i haven't seen that but i'm aware of the
problem it's
2000 it's a documentary from 2014 and it
starts with a
kid just crying and they're like why are
you crying
and so china had declared
pc rooms internet video game addiction a
national emergency
so they said it's okay we set up these
centers and
you could either poison or drug your kid
and just drop them off there
like or you could lie to them and tell
them they're going to like a camping
trip and then just drop them off there
and then they stay there for 90 days
because that's and it's like a prison
and these the start of the movie yeah
look at the kid crying you see that
wow so so they they can't stop playing
video games they can't stop watching
porn
they can't function so this thing
in in the movie at some point i'll spoil
it they escape like like
from uh is this a documentary yeah it's
a documentary
they escape from the mad house at one
point like the kids you know
they form a plan and they where do they
go they go to the pc room down the
street
they just can't they can't stop so wow
it almost looks like a independent film
that's why i asked to visit no it's a
documentary the way they've shot it is
very interesting because for me you know
me i don't smoke i don't drink i don't
do any of that
but i [ __ ] i've been to over a
thousand aaa meetings
and i don't drink what people why do you
do that i'm like because i can't stop
porn i can't stop video games i can't
start stop gambling
and i know that they have meetings for
that too but they're harder to find
they're more shameful there's less
people and if i go to a aaa room and i'm
talking
and there's a guy speaking about how he
got clean from alcohol
i just listened to him and every time he
says alcohol i replace it with porn
video game and i and i and i'm like
and not just that i'll do that in a last
case ditch scenario
but i'll i'll i'll go to all the
meetings i go to all the [ __ ]
meetings
and so i'm sitting on warcraft 2
and i'm and i'm something's missing from
my life and my rage and my anger and all
my
my addictions and my my mental illnesses
are coming out in this warcraft game and
i find this map that's perfect it's a
small map and it's called paintball and
it's just everyone dies everyone has one
hit point so one hit and you're dead so
it's more like a
like a chess speed ball game so the
games don't last more than 15 minutes
you have one peasant one paladin and one
wizard
and i killed at that game i killed
ev and and and within five minutes you
know like the
way it goes you bring down a blizzard
storm and you build a cannon tower or
whatever
and you know if you're going to win and
this is before five minutes because it's
a fast game
everything moves fast and you don't have
to wait for the wood to chop it's really
fast
and never [ __ ] with those games i
didn't have the this was before the ear
pieces
so within five minutes the game is sort
of on auto so you know it's like who can
do the things the fastest
then i start talking [ __ ] i'm gonna
skull [ __ ] your parents you dumb
[ __ ]
this is a kid like in oh my god and i'm
like like all
you know the way people talk like all
their demons come out right
and these and i'm playing kids and
they're like why what is a skull [ __ ]
and
i'm like like i am a horrible person
and then one day i i was the king of
this map
like in this one area in my life where
my art career is
kind of going good but not really and i
don't know how to be in a relationship
and
i'm just sort of lost in my my mid-20s i
don't know who the [ __ ] i am i don't
in this game i am god i'm god like you
know i'll go out and i'll be checked out
i'll be out with my friends three hours
a day playing this game
i'm not gonna lie it would be like all
day i'd be like oh i gotta go work and
so it's the first time in my lifetime
ten hours a day no no twelve like
16 18 hours 20 hours a day
um so i would play this game
and i would lie i started lying i
started lying to my friends about what i
was doing and when i was out i'd be
checked out they'd be talking about hey
what this new thing
we're gonna go here and i'd be like ice
storm ice storm
you know it's like
you